he'll injured teammates as soon as
possible so your med gun can recharge
before another hunter takes damage
during combat focus on healing the
hunter that the monster is actively
attacking use your healing burst to keep
yourself alive if you don't need it
save your burst for extra healing when a
teammate is close to death tranquilize
the monster as soon as you engage it
then switch to your med gun the tranq
will make it easier for your team to
track and fight the monster if the
monster is tranquilized and your
teammates are healed use the sniper
rifle to put a weak spot on the monster
hunters can be revived whether they're
dead or in captive be patient wait on
the outskirts of the battle until the
monster has lost interest in the body
then move in to revive the Lazarus
device will bring teammates back with no
strikes but their health will be low use
your healing burst as soon as they're
back on their feet
first is your only active human
abilities use it as often as possible to
keep you and your team healthy make your
personal cloak count keep yourself alive
at all costs coordinate with support to
keep yourself hidden as much as possible
if you die no one else is coming back
spread out your sniper shots so that
teammates with inaccurate weapons have a
greater chance of gaining a weak spot
Tyrel strength is her ability to heal
multiple targets at once get two or more
hunters and range of each healing
grenade blast to multiply healing output
when following tracks or bird sign use
the adrenaline field to hurry the team
to the monster start at the back of the
pack to bunch everyone up and avoid
leaving anyone behind when in combat
activate the adrenaline field to help
teammates move more quickly fire the
healing grenade launcher at your feet to
heal yourself
napalm grenades will continue to burn
the monster for a number of seconds so
light it up and go back to healing
you'll be dealing damage in the
background
you